is there anything one can do oneself to
advance the idea that a culture of
liberty and personal freedom is the
highest human value that that in freedom
their strengths that in a nut sort of
mindless July 4th stuff but that in
point of fact no matter what tradition
one comes from whether it's Islamic or
Jewish or Christian or Hindu that if
we're made in the likeness and image of
God if we live in if we're part of a
divinely ordained or at least a world in
which there is a predominant myth of
divinity and divine providence how do we
best play our part in that trauma and is
maximizing the ability the ability of
you to do what you want me to do what I
want as long as it doesn't take your
pocket or break your arm is that is
there something we can do to do that and
I don't know about you but I like the
idea that I can walk out of here and go
about my business and feel reasonably
secure that someone's not gonna punch me
in the nose and I can pursue my way of
life head home see my children celebrate
my country's independence and live in a
way that attempts to help the common
good along a bit without taking too much
out of it and hopefully tell that story
in a way that keeps people who for
whatever reason
have a variant Lee opposing view of the
virtues of that system is there any way
to change their mind and I like to think
one of the reasons I wrote the last book
I wrote was you know here's a story this
is not a bad story for us are we crazy
imperialist have we been insanely racist
have we committed genocide have we
bombed civilian populations yes yes yes
and yes have we done unspeakable things
yes will we do them again yes but in a
fallen world in a world where the only
thing that's absolutely predictable is
that the innocent will suffer and that
justice has to be done have we
ultimately been a force for good can I
think